von der urlaubswoche die mitunter einer
der schönsten wochen im jahr sein kann
wollen wir jetzt auf einen tag blicken
der wohl der schönste im leben sein kann
denn es ist die eigene hochzeit
unsere kollegin angelique tg ist dafür
bei einem paar live was heute heiraten
will
wie sehen sie angelique wie kann ich mir
solch eine hochzeit vorstellen ja
gallier und ihr freund andreas wollen
heiraten diese hochzeit wird aber so
ganz anders als eine normale hochzeit
wie man sie sich vorstellen muss ohne
freunde und ohne familie wie das das
paar beeinflusst und wie sie sich
vorbereitet haben das sind wir jetzt
kalia brenner und ihr freund andreas
wollen heiraten
gar nicht so einfach in zeiten zum chor
um die hochzeit verschieben kam aber
nicht in frage
aber egal ich habe mir gesagt gedacht
egal ich will diese gallier ist taschen
designerin und instagram star ihr freund
andreas psychologe beide haben sich vor
zwei jahren kennengelernt ihrer hochzeit
haben sie sich anders vorgestellt mit
freunden und familie
aber das fällt nun flach damit sie
morgen fast im kreis ihrer liebsten
heiraten können haben sie sich etwas
ganz besonderes ausgedacht
[Musik]
die feier wurde zwar schon abgesagt aber
galliers kleid kann mit einer letzten
lieferung aus mailand
ich sehe das kleid tatsächlich morgen an
[Musik]
ich dachte mein gott 36 34 ich weiß
nicht und weil alle friseure geschlossen
haben muss ihr zukünftiger ehemann ihr
noch schnell die spitzen schneiden
wenn das mal kein vertrauen ist na
hoffentlich gefällt die frisur
der nächste morgen in ihrer wohnung in
frankfurt jetzt wird es zeit für das
kleid es passt und langsam werden beide
nervös diese aufregung in deutscher und
ich bin die produkte kanadierin also
wenn er schon aufgeregt
[Musik]
jetzt muss nur noch sie samtkleid ins
auto passen und dann nichts wie los zum
standesamt
und genau da stehen wir jetzt auf dem
gelände vom standesamt in darmstadt
zusammen mit andreas und gallier seit
heute morgen ziemlich spät angekommen
was ist heute passiert
ich habe meinen ausweis tatsächlich
vergessen wir waren schon halbjahr
ausweisen
da müssen wir zurückfahren und die sind
so für euch eine heute ist eure
geheiratet heute wie ist es so ohne
familie und ohne freunde
naja ich habe es mir ganz anders
vorgestellt in dem sinne dass ich musste
ihr das kleid anziehen und das kann die
ganze aufregung vorher die teilt man
dadurch und er es war interessant ich
fand es schon ganz schön wie wir sind
gibt unser ding und deswegen halten wir
so was ja auch ganz gut aus auch wenn
was ein bisschen schief geht und am ende
geht es nur noch darum ist es für euch
nicht in frage gekommen die hochzeit zu
verschieben
also ich bin ein mensch ich lebe in die
jetzige im moment living genau und für
mich ist wichtig wir wissen nicht was
passiert in einem monat in einem jahr
ein halbes jahr und ich finde ich wollte
nicht warten ich wollte andreas heiraten
und das war mir ganz wichtig dass wir
heute hatten weil heute würde
ausgesuchten heute also ein ganz
besonderer tag
und das ist auch was anderes später für
unsere zukünftige kinder zu sagen hey
guys wir haben uns werden werden die
kommunen zeit geheiratet und das ist
auch was besonderes finden und bald geht
es eigentlich auch schon los um 13 uhr
oh mein gott ich bin schon aufgeregt
vorgestern und jetzt nicht was umgekippt
und ich bin doch schön dass würden dass
man während seiner zeit auch so schöne
dinge machen kann ja das was einem gut
tut wenn man sich nicht einschränken
müssen sofern dann kann man es ja
weitermachen und wir haben jetzt nur
lösung gefunden wie man liebt wirbel
umzugehen
dann wünsche ich alles gute das paar
wird als gutes beispiel vorausgehen und
sagen ja hochzeiten in corona das in
corona zeiten das funktioniert
dankeschön angelique und natürlich alles
gute für das braun